I'm James Davis back with another
swagger source do you guys know what a
thought is well I'm not talking about
those ideas in your head I thought as a
hoe the word thought is actually an
acronym for that hoe over there I
thought it's someone whose hoeing so
much out here in the streets that even
if you're face to face with this
individual someone across the street or
driving by is calling them that whole
thing moving forward if you're hanging
with the cool kids
or you want to sound cool in front of
your co-workers use the word thought to
describe somebody who everybody knows is
getting around now if you're describing
multiple hoes over there then you would
use the term thought ease I don't know
who the original thought was maybe
Marilyn Monroe I'm sure some of the
Kennedys were calling her a thot
maybe its Wilt Chamberlain the NBA Hall
of Famer who once scored a hundred
points in the game and also claimed to
have slept with over 20,000 women 20,000
he was a trailblazer in the thought
community he was getting it in he was
getting it in there's even a famous
family full of thoughts that we keep up
with if you see what I'm saying at the
end of the day respect yourself you
don't want to end up in a game of
thought potato you don't want someone
like me calling you a thot pocket it
happens so ladies and gentlemen keep it
together wrap it and tap it and hold
back the Beast